[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay this gonna be a quick review and
read retrospective of John Carpenter's
Escape from New York one of my all-time
favorites I know we're doing like a
whole John Carpenter thing on the show
it seems like all the movies that we're
gonna do her like John Carpenter I'm not
all of them but you know what's a lot we
gotta get John Carpenter out of the way
because John Carpenter was he was a
masters of the 80s flick oh yeah yeah
they were like flicks some of them were
films I can probably consider the thing
was a film probably Halloween was a film
yeah I don't know if I'd call that a
flick or not escape from New York was a
film too now they live was a flick it
was a gift lick but we're gonna do they
live what do they eventually do what
seriously but tom has he has been
purchasing all of the limited edition
like yes steelbook steelbook blu-rays of
John Carpenter's films not all of them
but just the ones we like the best yeah
it's from a company called Shout Factory
so I want to review these blu-rays as
they come up I think this is probably
the definitive version of Escape from
New York a lot of you guys who are
listening to this review I've already
seen this flick so I'm just gonna kind
of focus on for right now the steelbook
blu-ray version of it it's limited to
10,000 copies and it looks really cool
it's it opens up like a steelbook just
like it claims and it's kind of like a
tin can with really cool artwork yeah
the artwork is very nice yes nice and
it's executed really well it's not the
original cover art for this movie it's a
it's a reboot art but it looks really
good what do you think of it as a
graphic designer Jane I think it's
really beautiful like I really like the
color scheme but it's kind of like a
cool green color scheme and they kind of
have the Duke of New York they're like
Isaac Hayes like in the back of his
earring and says like that yeah they're
sure that I don't see you the movie
where snakes trying to get up over the
wall the president's shooting down at
the Duke of New York movie or at the
Statue of Liberty really big and
right it looks pretty cool yeah it's got
lots of extras it's got two CDs in it
let's do black CDs but the two DVDs yeah
and one of the DVDs is nothing but just
extras and it includes photographs of
like foreign poster art for the movie
period you know from the time it even
has photos of the original Escape from
New York board game from back which I
can't believe they they made that yeah
they did and it's a bit worth a lot of
money if you can find well yeah I guess
so I don't even remember seeing in the
story that you had to get the New York
it seemed you had to get the President
and you had to get the tape that was
alright I love the tape in the whole
movie because I'm sure like probably a
lot of you have seen it if you haven't
seen it you probably should but the
whole it's it's kind of like a sci-fi
dystopia type of movie where the premise
of it it's supposedly set in the future
of 1997 yeah 96 was the future yeah so
when the entire island of Manhattan has
become a prison and if you get convicted
of [ __ ] they just throw you in there and
just let you run around yeah everything
the movie starts off with kind of like a
brief explanation of what has happened
to New York and the United States the
the screenplay and the idea for this
movie actually they started working on
in 1973 and so it was in development
hell for a long time and they finally
released the movie in 1981 it claims in
the set up that in 1991 the crime crime
rate got so bad everything went up like
five thousand percent
I think it's 400 400 there was a
Saturday and then what was it 1994 they
roped off New York and turn your
remember when they did that in 1984 I
totally remember right and that's taking
place in 1997 so this is kind of like a
parallel universe past that's when this
has happened yeah come on point of view
now when we watch it but still the movie
still holds up it's still pretty cool it
looks like cross between 1980 and well
no it looks like 1980 in 1994 kind of
mixed together you say certain ways sort
of like that but well the cool thing
about it now I don't know if you
now here's one of the coolest things I
think that about getting this set the
blu-ray set is that there's all these
really cool documentaries and stuff like
that and I am like a sucker for
behind-the-scenes documentaries and I
particularly loved movies that are made
in the 70s and 80s when they use
practical effects you know because they
didn't have much of a budget you know so
they had to think of all these creative
ways to do the [ __ ] because they
couldn't afford you know they didn't
have CGI and they couldn't afford like
real big budget effects you know so some
of the effects in this are really
ingenious yeah especially for what they
paid for them yeah everything's
miniatures pretty much and matte
paintings yeah and you would never know
they're really alright and and the
opening scene shows the president's jet
Air Force One flying through the air and
you're kind of following next to it and
the clouds are going by and that was a
miniature I had no idea yeah it was a
bunch of cotton pulled into the shape of
class laid out on screens at different
levels yeah so there was clouds above
they showed it like unbeliev it doesn't
look like a real shot but you don't know
how they did it it looks good James
Cameron do that because yeah big huge
star James Cameron he used to be a
special-effects guy yeah and he worked
on some John Carpenter movies
backgrounds days and I think he did the
cotton plane thing right well what
happens is is how the movie starts is
well you know after it's a brief
explanation of what's happening in this
universe about New York being a prison
shows Air Force One and it's been
hijacked by basically like a Marxist
terrorist and she was a female - which
was kind of she yeah yeah she'd slipped
of pilots throat of Air Force One and
she's you know seeing that we're doing
this name of the people or whatever and
she crashes the plane right into a
building in New York New York's of
prison but the president actually
survives the crash they put him in like
a little crash capsule yeah like a
little red egg yeah and he survives it
the guy who is like the main warden over
the prison his name's Falk right Huck
hawk that's what his name is
Hawker hell yeah how yeah I'm not sure
how they pronounce it he goes in there
to try to rescue the president but they
already have custody of him and they're
holding him hostage and he has to
pull back so he goes back to his
headquarters and just so happens a new
prisoner is in processing into the New
York prison and it's a character by the
name of Snake Plissken the famous the
Phoenix named Christian and he's a war
hero and veteran of the Siberian wars of
the 1990s and he's being sent into New
York for a life sentence for bank
robbery now in this edition of the DVD
that I have in the steelbook edition
they actually show the deleted scene of
the robbery
and it was cut from the movie for
various reasons I kind of agree with
their decision to cut it from the movie
but it's good to see it well their
reasoning for deleting the scene because
as it is now the theatrical version of
the movie basically just says they
introduced Snake Plissken when he's
coming into the prison right and I think
they announced that he was in there for
bank robbery or whatever and he was
going for a life sentence now used to be
the original cut of the film had the
first scene was actually quite a long
scene isn't it like 12 minutes or
something about that and it showed the
bank robbery with Snake Plissken and his
buddy
buddy of his name is Taylor they were uh
they served together in those Siberian
right Taylor's got the limp
yeah and evidently he had help snake
during the war and snake was gonna pay
him back by cutting him into this bank
robbery yeah yeah and then really they
didn't really steal cash they stole
credit cards ATM cards or look like I
looking a big bank of yeah like prepaid
ATM cards yeah it was a there was a
snake needed Taylor because there was
some computer hacking involved they were
hacking the triad yeah that's right
which is all kind of futuristic for 1981
these concepts of yeah
prepaid ATM cards and
computer-controlled trains in a trance
what they call it the Transcontinental
subway yeah we supposedly a subway that
went underneath pretty much the entire
country like from every city to every
other major city which actually would be
nice and yeah and make a long story
short they get away in the
transcontinental subway but the cops
catch them and they kill Taylor but
really I kind of think it's best if the
you don't know anything about Sneha
askin when you first see him in the
movie that I believe well John Carpenter
and Kurt Russell as you affectionately
call him cross across all the crosses
just to save time today's time Kurt you
who I wish I called him the Kurt for a
while yeah but then I also called him
the Russell and then I just said now
he's the crustle yeah it was kind of
like my spinning on the hest which is
Charlton Heston and the ship which is
yeah so John Carpenter and crustle have
said that the reason that they cut this
whole bank robbery scene out was because
they didn't really say well we don't
want you to sympathize with Snake
Plissken but they wanted him to be a
more mysterious or an antihero type
character they didn't want him to
humanized at the beginning they didn't
want him to sympathetic at the beginning
right just so you weren't really sure
like I'm not really sure because I guess
it's better if your and I don't know
anything you don't know if he's gonna
break bad you don't know I was gonna
like end up siding with the criminals I
remember it I remember you know having
never seen that cutscene you don't
really know much about snake when he
shows yeah they don't give much a story
I was imagining the robbery is kind of a
violent robbery maybe some people were
shot and killed in it you know man like
maybe they shot some people to get this
money but when you actually see the
robbery was kind of a non-violent
robbery it was yeah it was just like a
sneaky Rob's like a sneaky robbery they
would they hacked some those high
security boxes what do you call them
yeah looks like they hacked the
safe-deposit box with a gym bag full of
these prepaid ATM cards and got out of
there there was some roll but there was
a robot in the bank - that was kind of
cool yeah telling everybody to get as
close as it was good so it wasn't the
violent armed robbery that I thought it
was having seen you know having never
seen the opening scene yeah well no okay
now the interesting thing about Kurt
Russell in this movie I really like Kurt
Russell in this movie he is just like so
stoic and he's really definitely in his
prime in this movie oh yeah he's about
30 honestly did not did John Carpenter I
think he said that he wouldn't
do this movie without him without Kurt
Russell because at this stage I mean I
know it's hard to imagine now because
Kurt Russell has been in so many action
movies and stuff like that subsequently
but before that I mean when Kirk when
Kurt Russell was really young he was in
mostly disney comedies yeah he had just
got done he was Nels like I could yet do
an Elvis with fur and the carpenter did
Elvis aw yeah yeah yeah and Kurt Russell
played Elvis and he thought he was great
wrong so he's like well I'm gonna do
this escape from New York and Kurt
Russell has to be in it cuz I think the
studio wanted he said no they wanted
Charles Bronson or Tommy Lee jam or I
think they said it was or something like
that but he thought they would be too
old and and you know without this movie
the crustle would have never been able
to do Stargate you never would have been
able to do soldier and you know so many
other I don't think he would ever shown
up at a Tarantino flick yeah because
this was kind of one of his like you
people don't know I would school with
Clinton yeah between like kindergarten
and seventh grade oh yeah yeah I know I
know the Tarantino he doesn't have like
a Tarrant you can't really shorten that
can't you know that II know tear the tip
I remember back when teachers were
pulling him out of the damn dirt going
with the girls you can tell that story
little Timmy's elementary school when we
do a counselor probably at some point
all right but yeah so the cool really
the coolest thing about Kurt Russell
this is my very favorite scene is when
he's first brought in like how it gets
played by Lee Van Cleef who's yeah yeah
and I love it I love his voice and he's
just like such a great character and
they're yeah now I love when Lee Van
Cleef brings Kurt Russell into the
office to like give him the deal yeah
we'll give you a pardon if you go into
New York and find the president you only
have 24 hours right yeah to find him and
bring him back out and stuff like that
and Lee Van Cleef goes that now does he
said president's plane has gone down in
New York prison you guys president of
why
that is alright mister and the great
time cursors going president of what
like just all really sarcastic I [ __ ]
that's my favorite line of the whole
yeah it's funny it was pretty cool and
not think nothing about this okay not
only did this role make the crustal the
crustle made this role yeah really vital
they wouldn't have been the same without
it and carpenter told him to develop
this character so yeah it was a very
collaborative yeah that's not a liked
about carpenter carpenters early films
at least it was kind of like it was done
between France it was sick yeah that's
kind of a scene films and they were
independent films but they had unions
and studios involves but really when you
look at him they felt a lot like
independent films yeah but the crustle
invented Snake Plissken the hair of the
eyepatch
the that stomach tattoo the stomach Ted
I mean motorcycle boots with the arrow
head stuck in the field point arrow head
stuck in the tips even the the winter
camouflage that's all that's all crustle
is invention yes and because Lee Van
Cleef was playing in it cross it was
impressively Van Cleave how can you not
be and Van Cleef was you know of course
from the westerns yeah there's an
old-school Western actor yeah Seok
Russell says [ __ ] it okay I'm gonna play
Snake Plissken as Clint Eastwood yeah so
if you really look at Snake Plissken his
voice and everything that's East for the
voice in the mannerisms very very Clint
Eastwood ass it worked though it did
yeah and I really didn't click until the
crustle said that in his interviews
because actually I'm just doing Eastwood
oh yeah yeah where you are we gotta do
an Eastwood flick if I'm gonna do at
Eastwood flick it's gotta be High Plains
Drifter because that's a paranormal
movie it is yeah there was a driver II
love that it's my favorite western yeah
and I've got a lot of people did and I
didn't I'm not I'm not a huge western
fan but I really do like I saw it
several times before I realized that
that was the ghost of the dead sheriff
come back to take the town yeah for
cowardice yeah he was a drifter from a
higher plane yeah that's what they were
talking about see mind blown yeah
at the end he walks off into the
distance and he gets smaller and smaller
small invent and then vanishes vanishes
yes the headstone of the dead yeah yeah
oh this they caught me I didn't notice
that it's funny so well see when I saw I
saw it when I was a kid but then like
when I saw it when I was older I'm like
oh obviously yeah but when I was a kid I
didn't I didn't get it well you wouldn't
get it when you didn't get it yeah I
mean it's pretty obvious when you're
growing up when you're watching it go
though I brought it up to my stepdad
after I figured it out it says hey Bill
did you know that that's about a ghost
it's not it's not about ghosts it is and
then I showed him the scenes he's like
oh yeah it is because that's what that
man alright so before I forget one of
the good things about escape from New
York that I was got to bring up is this
was a cheap movie I think it was only
five maybe six million dollar budget
yeah today if you were to try to do that
movie and probably a hundred million
dollars probably well yeah but here's
the rad thing okay now how they did is
they just edited a bunch of bunch of
locations yeah I love this it kills me
like I said I love behind the scenes
documentaries not nowadays because now
it's like oh we made it in a computer so
it's a bunch of nerd sit in front of a
computer making [ __ ] and see yeah yeah
yeah like or a bunch of actors say in
front of green screen that's no fun to
watch it's fun to watch [ __ ] from the
70s and 80s and they're like well we had
to make stuff with gaffer tape but no
way they didn't know how to cuz like
okay this is the most impressive thing
to me one they couldn't get permits to
film in New York City obviously because
it was supposed to be in New York or
specific all burned out it was supposed
to be empty and stuff yeah that makes me
a post apocalyptic apostle apocalyptic
New York that's been taken over by
criminals right so they couldn't film it
in New York obviously because it was
full of people however their location
scout found a huge area of st. Louis
Missouri burned out that had been burned
out like there was a huge fire and a
bunch of the buildings had been
abandoned and stuff like that and they
hadn't really bothered to rebuild yeah
it was very dangerous down there but
that's where they were gonna film it and
it looks great yes so they just had like
their their art department or whatever
come in and like redress is that to kind
of look more like New York and stuff
like that
and I had no idea yeah I had no idea
yeah they're not Stan's they're on
location yeah that is an actual city and
that's it
and all the furnishings in those
buildings that's those are the real
furnishings some of some some of the
locations you know they roughed them up
they spray-painted the insides of it
yeah yeah when they're showing burned
out st. Louis they're portraying it as
New York but it just looks fantastic
yeah you wouldn't really think about
that I got across with this suppressed
mac-10 blown holes through walls walls
and busting out glass and running away
from my guests cannibals
guys that came out underneath the sewers
remember that yes yes yeah I guess they
were kind of kitchen I think the woman
said that they were running out of food
there's the end of the month they're
running out of food okay came up out of
the yeah that was like prank that was
kind of a subtle in the end they grabbed
her and pulled her down and down into
the floor and then you never see her
they just ate eight people oh but before
another and the other awesome thing
about the special effects okay you know
how the early shots where they're doing
like the the computer simulation of like
going into New York yes that was on okay
well it looks like wireframe like
computer animations of like that which
was one it was kind of available in a
haze yeah but it was too expensive
really to put in a movie basically you
only saw that it's like vectorscope is
what it looked like yes II was asteroids
and asteroids the logs which every yeah
like every time I had seen that movie
even where I saw it back in the eighties
like computers I assumed it was computer
graphics it is not do you know what they
did they made a miniature yeah they had
a miniature of New York City that they
built out of like cardboard and Shimla's
and stuff yeah and they put white tape
like glowing tape all around all the
buildings so that that was all you could
see yeah and it looked like and it
looked like vector CGI yeah but it
wasn't it was I had no idea that that
was how they did that it was done with
[ __ ] glowing tape yeah all of the
computer graphics that were used in the
movie were actually just some kind of
tricks like that photographic tricks and
animations but it works it looks really
good especially on blu-ray yeah there
are no computer graphics in it no no and
I found that amazing because it never
especially that that vector graphic
thing that blew my mind because I always
just thought that was yeah
computer-generated carpenter and his
team
just did a really good job you know I
mean they made a really big immersive
world out of just different locations
just sewn together yeah edited together
it looks really good yeah anyway where
were we okay the plane goes down then me
talked and Hawk makes a deal with them
to go in and go get the president yeah
okay although I love this too he's like
okay well we'll give you a full pardon
if you go in there and you can bring the
president out in 24 hours and Kurt
Russell is kind of like yeah whatever
give me a play and I'm just gonna escape
or whatever now what how does it tell
him like he does this right before he's
gonna drop him off and yeah right before
he's gonna go into New York he's like oh
by the way I'm gonna put this [ __ ] in
your neck
yeah he's explosives you can inject it
is that if you don't come back in 24
hours it's gonna blow your head off
yeah I've always wondered whether or not
there was a trick I wonder that too how
did they come up with that and such
short notice
yeah blow Civ capsules that could be
injected into you yeah and here's the
thing - and I noticed this the last time
I was gonna have seen it many times but
we watched it recently
preparation for this when he puts it in
his neck I'm pretty sure he says you
have to be back here by like 15 minutes
before the 24 hours is up I don't
remember that now I think he said
something like that there was something
about 15 minutes like before you know I
mean so then but then at the end when
he's getting out of New York and they're
coming to rescue him it's definitely
like five seconds yeah it's like five
seconds like right down to the wire
obviously and he doesn't blow up no he
doesn't blow up and they and the guy
runs over he says oh I got to give you
the antidote I think I might've and they
were gonna kill it but they were gonna
neutralize it yeah I think the whole
thing was this was a trick it might have
been they keep him from running away
because they had to give him a glider
because they said well you can't just go
into New York's everyone will see you
and all this other stuff and they didn't
want him to be seen so they gave him a
glider and they said you have to land on
top of the World Trade Center and then
take the elevator all the way down so no
one will see you come in - yeah I'll
even have to back up Hawk offers him a
deal just to rescue the president all
right in exchange for a pardon he takes
that deal so they say I liked really
liked to party they took him into a room
and they just laid his equipment out
they were gonna issue him a bunch of
equipment it was a mac-10 let's press or
scope on it three magazines full of
ammunition
stainless Smith & Wesson revolver with
scope on it some ninja throwing stars
because you know everyone knows a
tracker he could wear on his hand a big
old timer yeah yeah and a walkie-talkie
yeah well you have that saying he had
that thing that was supposed to tell him
where the president was to like that was
supposed to be monitoring his heart rate
or something yeah it was like a tracker
they had on his hand yeah that was
another one it would like show him the
direction in distance yeah and it was
just had black or red LEDs on it it
really didn't explain how it worked
it's whatever technology right and to
get in there the only way to get in
there was they really put him in a jet
glider remember he was the only guy that
was rated to pilot this jet glider yeah
that was one of the reasons why they put
him on this mission I don't know why the
police force has a jet glider like this
a special-operations jet glider laying
around but they did and it was a really
good scene when he lands on the top of
the Empire State Building where's the
World Trade Center oh yeah it's our
World Trade Center
yeah that yeah he couldn't really land
on top of the Empire State Building do
you know it's pointy and he gets down on
an elevator anyway we don't want I don't
want to spoil the whole story I don't
want to encourage people that have seen
the movie before to go ahead and see it
again [ __ ] you know even though we spoil
pretty much every go see it it's pretty
cool they probably have it on instant
watch on YouTube and if you like it I
really recommend the steelbook still the
blu-ray looks beautiful though
it really doesn't crease it was lit just
a catchy Allah be well yeah and like I
said John Carpenter I really like John
Carpenter he's made some shitty movies
okay well not shitty but questionable
some of them he's made some questionable
movies but a lot of his movies are
really really good and I really do feel
like he's very inspired by Dario Argento
and other jello type movies because the
lighting scheme is pretty in Escape from
New York there was some stuff in Prince
of Darkness too that reminded me very
much of a jolla movie Dario jente the
just the kind of primary color the weird
lights and the lurid kind of colors and
stuff like that so I think there is like
a lot of and I noticed in an escape from
New York like all those green shafts of
light coming down through the streets
and everything like that that is very
you know it's kind of like he was moving
for one
world into another like when he was in
the police stations and things like that
and when they showed the deleted scene
widow the rock yeah it looked very clean
and industrial it's very white very
sterile it goes from that into almost
kind of like once they get into the
prison it's almost kind of like you said
like agile a horror movie it's a lot of
reds red lights green lights blue lights
lighten up the streets
yeah and and when he goes to a lot of
the buildings are like kind of
old-fashioned looking like when he goes
to see brain yeah you know who was an
old friend of his and he's kind of like
the Duke of New York's guy and stuff
like that
and he goes to see him and doesn't he
lives in a library right him yeah him
and his girlfriend news play-fight yes
funny they mixed like two or three
different locations together the front
of it they I think it was either a
library or a some kind of Cornell's
example look like from the outside but
when he goes inside it was actually USC
yeah okay it's a library at USC yeah it
was you know they it's just like like
brains layer it kind of looks like it
looks like an old school library the
only safe school when you say brain they
parent know what you're talking about
there's a lot of really cool characters
once they get into the prison you got a
guy named cabby this played by Ernest
Borgnine it's almost an all-star cast
yeah and cabbie is like he's like the
comic relief yes good guy then they
introduced him they when they introduced
and introduced them into the wood in a
way that you know that this is a good
person
yeah yeah he's memory sing-along he's
watching the show yeah he's super
lovable in this movie and I see comic
relief like not in a stupid like zany
kind of way but he just kind of like
provides a little kind of like the
stairs he's nobody yeah he's also kind
of like axes kind of like the everyman -
yes some of the audience is supposed to
repair the weird thing and I think I'm
and I think I asked you about this when
we were watching it last time I was like
well why is cabbie in prison what is he
in prison for yeah I don't know if he is
in prison for something specifically or
if he just stayed in New York after it
got used in as a prison just because he
liked it that's because it's a weird
thing by the timeline given in the
beginning of the movie that the prison
is really only for I think four years
old maybe something like that yeah maybe
six years old I have he said he'd been
riot driving that
same taxicab on the exact same streets
for 33 years so what did he do did he
stay in Manhattan that was what is it
yeah the thing is is that he did say can
you take me with you snake he didn't
want out so I don't know maybe he was
convicted of a crime went back found his
old taxi cab and so I don't know I was
just kind of he seemed like the kind of
person who would just stay there because
he liked it and then later on after you
meet that character you meet two other
characters brain and his girlfriend
Maggie brain is kind of like the local
scientist that mixed all the gasoline so
yeah he makes gasoline so he's very
value right so they can get you know
electric power for you know the
generators in certain genres and they
can drive cars but only only the leaders
of of New York you know like the upper
crust of New York can do that
yeah and mostly we're talking about the
Duke of Duke of New York played by Isaac
Hayes Isaac Hayes in the most pimping
automobile ever yeah it's got
chandeliers it's got chandeliers mounted
on the hood Isaac Hayes does a really
good job he's good man a guy has the
deepest voice ever he does have an
awesome voice I know I mean it's almost
as deepest I think it's even deeper than
James Earl Jones yeah imagine if Darth
Vader actually was being played by Isaac
Hayes Metin Isaac Hayes was cast as dog
food there'd be something else up hi
yeah I would like that actually I think
we're them plans they're damn force
strong with one Wow and then when he was
like questioning Leia he'd have been
like don't make me slap oh yeah yeah but
it's an all-star cast I also want to
give a shout out Jay to Donald Pleasance
yes is the president the awesome segreto
well the awesome thing about Donald
Pleasence is that even though he usually
plays kind of serious roles like Danny
played Blofeld and some of the you know
some of the James Bond movies and you
know he plays dr. Loomis and all the
Halloween movies and stuff like that but
he's actually according to everyone who
knew him like a super funny guy he's a
riot a lot of the crazy tortures that
they
like all the crazy stuff that the Duke
of New York and all his minions like due
to the president in escape opening like
putting the way bottom and like tying
over to the wall and shooting him and
making him say you're sick in New York
ain't number one and all this stuff that
was Donald Pleasence his idea yeah well
things about carpenter they were
carpenter to let his actors improve
their own roles yeah tweak their own
characters like AC he always seemed like
a cool guy to me like he always seemed
like real laid-back and real kind of
like well it's a collaborative process
he's not super bossy or anything like
yeah and his wife's in it she played
plays Maggie her name's Adrienne Barbeau
yeah she's in it and both of her boobs
are in it so it's all three of us the
Russell's the kruskal's first wife is in
it too she was the girl who in chock
full o'Nuts it got pulled through the
floor I forgot all about that her name
again she was I don't even remember but
she was only in it for like two minutes
yet two or three minutes she would she
like asked him for a cigarette right
yeah like yeah then she got pulled you
got with his name all the constant of
the snakes I got [ __ ] to do another
thing I like about this might have much
time you know another thing I like about
this movie too and I like that they
don't explain this is that when he gets
into New York and starts interacting
like with all the criminals and stuff
like that and every time he says what
his name is or every time somebody says
hey this is snake Plissken yeah every
single person says I thought you were
dead yeah I know he's like famous but
they don't really Snake Plissken thought
you would did yeah that's like a running
gag right yeah well I think it's because
of the deleted scene Wendy by the bench
yeah I think what happened was is that
word out on the street was Snake
Plissken got shot but no but Snake
Plissken 's Frant army friend yes Taylor
got shot
yes I think that's what they who they
thought was dead okay they just heard
about a robbery and and Snake Plissken
was in it and somebody got shot so it
must been so must have been having yet I
guess in another way that's another
classroom like taking that bank robbery
scene out because I kind of like not
knowing what that job yeah that not them
not explaining it's like everybody knows
who he is and they don't really tell you
why everybody
big news yeah so yeah robbing the
Federal Reserve yeah big news I'm in big
news yeah everyone every criminal would
go oh that's a good one yeah now there
was a sequel to escape from New York
yeah and it's nowhere near as good as
the original but that's not on crustle
cross all really his work in that movie
he nailed it he brought snake back it
was good but what was wrong with escape
from LA was that they basically just
reboot rebooted escape from New York
it was the same you want the same
plotline but it was almost a parody of
Escape from New York yeah I still want
to get that on on blu-ray just to have
my collection I like this to seek
Russell doing criminal thing you know
doing doing sneaky things you know and
there was a lot going on in that movie
but the CG didn't really hold up over
time I think Escape from New York is
kind of proof that sometimes less is
more
well yeah really the only I saw escape
from LA one time and the only indelible
image I have of that is crustle with the
bad surfing green screen yeah and they
was shooting I think by this not a
service server at the same time I think
I think yeah I think yeah I think you're
right it's pretty ridiculous and not not
ridiculous in a good way yeah now the
reason that it's taken us so long to do
this review because this was gonna be
our next review
but we've been like waiting to do it
because I little bit well we got held up
a little bit because tom has been
warning me to make a Snake Plissken
shirt t-shirt yeah and this thing is
badass
and it took me like forever yeah she
came she'd get around to making the fur
I like the very first design that came
up but I didn't like the snake yeah I
didn't say we had to find the right
snake to make this look really yeah and
if you check your screen you'll see what
we're talking about yes so that's
available for its on our Azazel story
yeah that's available for any Escape
from New York fans I already got a
couple buddies that want a copy if you
go to our Zazzle services a SOCOM slash
13 o'clock there's a snake Plissken
shirt on there I've also updated all of
our other shirts because they had
project entertainment network on them so
I
yes change it to our new website so
they've all been updated and I added
another one just it has a logo and that
it has like pictures of us inside a
clock that's yeah we couldn't do a
straight-up escape from New York
shirt you know of course of copywriting
but you can do a Snake Plissken shirt I
put Plissken on there and have a picture
of snake yeah yeah that that'll do it
people know you talk dirt in the cup you
[Laughter]
say so myself so is there anything else
you would like to say about escape from
New York
oh that limited-edition steelbook this
came from me it is very nice it looks
good that's the well I like the artwork
on the front because it's like kind of
minimalist yeah and I also have that
they live edition of the same thing
we're gonna have to talk about English
yeah we're gonna have to do they live
also yeah cuz he just got that one the
other day ten I'm gonna order the fog
yes see you so like sometimes I do I
like to pick on John Carpenter sometimes
about because you know cuz of Prince of
Darkness and yeah vampires or whatever
that one was he made but honestly
probably like 80 85 percent of his
movies were really good it was just only
a few that I didn't like I you know what
I even liked his Stephen King adaptation
Christine which a lot of people don't
but I really really liked it and I
actually really liked I think it was
Keith Gordon at the plate Arnie I
thought he was really good in that like
I thought he did like a good transition
from like nerd to like rayji greaser
type a guy I think I think carpenter was
best when he was young and hungry and in
earlier days I think later on once some
of it started to suffers like he was
trying to make it quickly yeah yeah his
later stuff does he was trying to make
it a little more mainstream because you
know some of his best movie his best
movie PSP was the thing and yeah easily
and it flopped that's the time yeah it
took years for that movie to I think it
was very ahead of its time it was ahead
of its time
so was this game from New York yeah
skate from New York was ahead of its
time in the day
although Escape from New York was
actually a pretty big hit when it came
out well it made like way more than its
money but yeah it made it was and
honestly the thing made more than its
money it like it made money but not as
much as they were projecting yeah so
they kind of considered it a failure
because it wasn't making his move it
didn't make as much they're still
merchandising off the
movie yes they have it's an ironic they
have brand-new Snake Plissken action
figures like GI Joe oh yeah so you can
have your own little puzzles crustle
you can sleep with him right next to you
on the pill you didn't yeah when was
1993 I was in the Army I bought it at
the pawn shop right outside the front
gate for Campbell Kentucky yeah yeah
nine month it was the nine millimeter
version this is not Cobre it was an
Ingram mac-10 just like the one the
crustle had but I didn't have the
suppressor on it of course name is
semi-auto say you were your own across
all not really yeah I just I just saw it
there and they lit Hill m1 250 bucks for
says yeah I'm gonna get that I had it
for a few months and then the MPS took
it away from me oh I went out shooting
it all right off the post
and came back on the post I was riding
my motorcycle I had it your tank bag
well they stopped me on random stop
coming into the main gate they say you
carrying any firearms II like that yeah
I got a mac-10 in that tank bag right
there and so to step away from the
motorcycle they took it out they called
it they called their chief community
this this concept this is within arm's
reach this carry this is considered
carry a concealed weapon and I said you
can't shoot a mac-10 ride a motorcycle
at the same time you need to ask so they
go well we're gonna take it you're gonna
have to get a letter from your battalion
commander where we give this thing back
did you get it back I wasn't gonna go
tell my battalion commander about that
he would have reduced me and rank right
that was Mike Russell story all you
needs an iPod needs an IV that's right
okay well we hope you guys are enjoying
these movie reviews sorry it's taking so
long to get this one up but like I said
I was not really reviews that were like
there's more like just discussions on
them yeah that's good yeah and you know
so we're gonna try and put some more up
and like I said we have a huge list of
like
I get through I don't even know what
we're gonna do next but we'll see but
yeah we'll see and if you want a Snake
Plissken t-shirt that I designed then go
to zazzle.com slash Thursday check it
out and there's one on there and there's
a bunch of our 13 o'clock shirts on
there too that I just updated so go
check it out and other than that was is
there anything else we need today
nothing